every experience is an equal there's got
to be some people that you enjoy working
with more than others you know there's
an X Factor and usually something
without even consciously making a
decision I just know that yeah I want to
work with them did you think about that
with Dave when you met him for for never
mind oh you'd be working together
forever totally I didn't know that but
when I the first day I walked into
rehearsal with Nirvana out in the valley
Kurt had sent me a cassette a week
before it Butch here's our new Drummer
Dave girl he's the best drummer in the
world and then they started playing
songs and he's right because it was
recorded on a Boombox was instantly just
massive Distortion but I could tell even
though it sounded horrible how tight it
sounded and then I walked into the
rehearsal room and Dave jumped up the
Scoopy guy hi I'm Dave what's nice to
meet you I think he weighed like 135
pounds or something and then he ran back
on the kit and I said well run through a
song you guys and they played a song and
I it was they played teen spirit and wow
it just crushed me how good he was and
how good they sound you knew off rip the
first time you heard it I started pacing
around the room uh I used usually I take
notes like little Arrangement things or
whatever I just I just just taking it
all in they finished the song and Kurt
was like what do you think Butch I went
play it again yeah and then I took more
notes down but it was incredible